on the mound for the padres tonight
getting start number five appearance
number 10 is ryan weather i'm really
excited i'm really excited to see the
left-hander twirl tonight as don
mentioned nine games four starts prior
to tonight great numbers opponents only
hitting 146 and 26. i think in those
four starts he's only allowed six hits
and 14 in the third in these pitches
whip is .70
fly ball out towards shallow left center
here comes fam diving in and fam makes
the catch
sliding on in in left center field is
tommy pham for out number one one left
fielder to another right out of the gate
creating some excitement taking away a
base hit tommy pham laying out kelly
thought that was going to fall for sure
through the first and hannigan's out oh
ryan just lulled him to sleep with the
pick-off boot hannager was kind of still
in the process of taking his lead
and then weathers who didn't even appear
to be looking that way just off the back
of the rubber slung it over
drives this one to right field and deep
profile going back gonna be over his
head and one hops
up and over the fence out there the
ground rule double we'll place runners
at second and third and that kind of
costs the mariners
really because if that ball stays in the
yard and just goes off the wall lewis
would have scored
but it is second and third as a result
with two down two bases on that one so
as donnie mentioned now second and third
ryan weathers can get out of this
putting up a zero up there in the top of
the first jacob nottingham coming up
here the first baseman for the m's oh
and two swinging demands weathers comes
back to strikeout nottingham and in the
inning without a run crossing the plate
no runs kabula hits a pick off that
looms very large and two men left in
scoring position on the mound is justice
sheffield for the mariners eighth start
for the young left-hander quite a talent
he's got a good arm 39 innings more hits
than any pitch not a lot of strikeouts
fewer than innings pitch at 31 opponents
hitting 280. lead runner on a good start
here's jerickson profile
roller will have to get one
seeger makes a play one down profile is
out 5-3 kyle seger hustling over in
front of j.p crawford to make the play
weather's ready and he delivers swing
and a line driving a left center field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
how about that mayfield the turn at
second goes back to the bag
just as sheffield
with a base in in the left center field
and look at the applause inside the
mariners third base dugout and they get
that ball
for justice's first major league hit
justice sheffield with a solid base hit
end of the gap in left center look at
the smile on his face over there at
first base and the mariners have two on
here at the top of the second on
sheffield's first major league hit way
to go kid i'll look back at second now
the one two from weathers that's reach
four grounded off the left side of the
mound tatis has got it behind the bag at
second kind of slings it a little bit
wide to first but hosmer reaching
towards right field able to bring it in
and in the inning no runs a couple of
two out singles one out one on here's
hassan kim andrei still in search of
their first hit
on the ground down the line into the
left field corner very quickly
nola headed for third and maybe beyond
yep they're going to try and send him
the throw they'll be none and the padres
strike first on top one to nothing great
battle by hassan kim there fouled off
some good breaking balls as well as
changeups to keep this bad alive austin
noel does not have blazing speed he gets
the green light and he's going to break
it down just to play it safe
nice pop-up slide kim with an rbi double
strike nothing in one on mitch haniger
walked against ryan weathers first time
up padres have a one-to-nothing lead
here over seattle the 0-1
swing hammered out to left field mitch
haniger with a big blast to left and
gone
thirteenth home run for a hammer and
hannah's 31st run batted in canada got a
94 mile an hour fastball up and in and
did he ever turn on it
was a pretty good fastball looked like
it's on the inside corner and elevated
but henniger can handle the high
fastball when you look at the mariners
lineup he's one of the few that can
catch up to it at the top of the zone
that's ten games fernando at 3 43 a
couple of doubles four home runs
and nine runs batted in
sharply hit and through the left side
handle left field touch he's got a base
hit trying for two throw to second he'll
get there
wow didn't see that coming he's
unbelievable he's took off turns it into
a double now a shimmy this kid is
amazing hanging slider after two
change-ups fair ball and even with the
spin turn and good throw fernando gets
to second base easy second pinch hit
appearance of the season for java joe
he is squaring he gets it down nicely
done
throw over his shoulder for the out
and the sacrifice is complete
out of the lead off spot today tommy
offer one with a walk taking off for
third is mateo fam takes a ball throw
ends up in left field and mateo will
scamper home to put the padres on top
two to one air throw from tom murphy and
you talk about manufacturing a run there
you go speed kills and it can't be top
base is filled with friars padres have
taken a 2-1 lead in the fifth inning
ozzo for two again sheffield now getting
a third look at him here tonight hosmer
for a base hit
family score here comes profar the throw
is up the line
throw gets away
tatis is going to try it he's in two
three runs will score on to third goes
hosmer and the padres take a 5-1 lead
mariners throw the ball all over the
place and the padres will score three
fernando here he comes he never stops
look at the way these guys run the bases
that doesn't get people excited and you
can hear it folks in this building are
pumped up
bottom of the seventh inning of petco
padres a 6-1 lead over the mariners
looking for an eighth straight win
down the line towards the corner and
that's going to be
a fair ball that rattles around and the
second base goes tatis
second double the night for fernando
absolutely cooked it down the left field
line
short hops the
left field wall and got his second
double
murphy at third nobody out
ground ball to tatis that one will score
tatis
gets the out
mainfield gets an rbi
6-3 ball game here's the pitch on the
way swinging a ground ball slow roller
third base line bare-handed by malanson
the throw to first low when it gets on
by hosmer here comes hagerty on to score
and the mariners still have a pulse here
in the top of the ninth inning now the
shark with the o2
i think he went around the check yes he
did ball game over
strikes out lewis to end the ball game